dem forschungsteam der europäischen
organisation für kernforschung ist ein
sensationeller fund gelungen
das hat ein bisher unbekanntes teilchen
entdeckt das aus vier quarks besteht und
das erste einer neuen teilchen klasse
sein könnte es ist das exotischste
teilchen das je entdeckt wurde diese
neue zusammensetzung zu einem tetra
quark könnte jetzt sogar einblicke in
die wirkungsweise der starken
wechselwirkung bieten kriegs um secure
shell gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
pixum gibt es jetzt übrigens auch auf
die ohren als podcast die links zu
spotify und apple podcasts sind in der
video beschreibung das europäische
kernforschungszentrum cern ist eines der
weltweit größten zentren für
physikalische grundlagenforschung hier
werden die fundamentalen gesetze des
universums untersucht indem man die
kleinsten bestandteile unserer materie
erforscht die elementarteilchen dabei
wurde jetzt ein neuartiges teilchen
entdeckt das so noch nie gesichtet wurde
ein tetra quark das sich aus vier quax
des gleichen typs zusammensetzt kurz
gesagt sind quasi die fundamentalen
bausteine der materie die protonen und
neutronen im atomkern sind aus je drei
quarks zusammengesetzt sie werden von
einer der vier grundkräfte der physik
zusammengehalten von der starken
wechselwirkung schon in den letzten
jahren zeigten experimente dass auch
teilchen mit mehr als zwei oder drei
quarks existieren es wurden tetra quarks
pentax und sogar hexa quarks gefunden
aber alle quark teilchen die man bisher
kannte bestehen immer aus mindestens
zwei verschiedenen sorten von quarks
nicht so das neu entdeckte teilchen es
wurde bei experimenten mit dem lhc b
gefunden dass es einer von sechs
riesigen detektoren des weltgrößten
teilchenbeschleunigers large hadron
collider kurz lhc die winzigen teilchen
der materie werden nämlich in
überdimensionalen anlagen untersucht
dazu lassen forschungsteams die teilchen
in einem gigantischen
ringförmigen beschleunigers mit
annähernder lichtgeschwindigkeit in
einem starken magnetfeld
aufeinanderprallen
damit sie in ihre einzelteile zerfallen
auf diese art wurde auch das bekannte
higgs boson teilchen gefunden dass man
auch als gottesteilchen kennt und das
nur eine zehntelsekunde existierte die
spektakulärste entdeckung des lhc
riesigen detektoren zeichnen ähnlich wie
die foto sensoren an der digitalkamera
auf in welche richtung und wie weit die
fragmente der atome auseinander fliegen
mit denen standen daten können dann die
eigenschaften der elementarteilchen
rekonstruiert werden das jetzt entdeckte
neuartigen teilchen ist sehr kurzlebig
und im vergleich mit einem proton oder
neutronen also den üblichen
bestandteilen aller atomkerne ja ist
seine masse deutlich größer etwa
siebenmal so groß aber das ist noch
nicht das bemerkenswerteste daran die
besonderheit des teilchens ist dass es
aus vier gleichen quarks besteht und
dann auch noch aus dem besonders
seltenen charm quarks quarks sind die
grundbausteine unserer materie denn aus
diesen elementarteilchen bestehen nach
aktuellem stand der physik die hadronen
also teilchen die anders als lab tonen
der starken wechselwirkung unterworfen
sind zu diesen hadronen gehören zum
beispiel die protonen und neutronen ein
proton beispielsweise besteht aus drei
quarks noch im 19 jahrhundert sieht man
atome für unteilbar das rutherford atom
modell zeigte dann dass das atom aus dem
atom kern und hüllen elektronen besteht
und mit der kernphysik wurde der aufbau
des atomkerns aus protonen und neutronen
entschlüsselt in den 1930 er jahren ging
man davon aus dass war mit den fünf
elementarteilchen protonen neutronen
elektronen und neutrinos schon den
kompletten aufbau der materie kannte
aber mit der zeit wurden immer neue
missionen und mario nnen die gemeinsam
die gruppe der hadronen bilden entdeckt
in der höhenstrahlung und später mit
teilchenbeschleunigern konnten hunderte
von hadronen entdeckt werden weshalb man
bis heute vom teilchen so spricht dass
sich atome im periodensystem durch die
unterschiedlichen protonen zahlen des
kerns ordnen lassen wurde auch für die
hadronen nachdem teil
gesucht aus denen sie sich
zusammensetzen und damit nach einer sub
struktur um sie zu ordnen diese teilchen
sind die quarks und zu allen quax gibt
es ein antiteilchen mit entgegengesetzte
elektrische ladung die anti kriegs erst
die atome dann den neutronen protonen
und elektronen es wurden mit der zeit
also immer kleinere bausteine der
materie gefunden bis hin zu den winzigen
quarks sind sie also die kleinsten
teilchen die es gibt nach der
stringtheorie die ja nicht belegt ist
sind die kleinstmöglichen objekte die
sich physikalisch beschreiben lassen
winzige schwingen der energie fädchen
die strings jedes fältchen stellt
demnach je nach schwing verhalten ein
materieteilchen da aber die theorie ist
bisher durch noch nichts belegt und so
sind bis dato die quarks die kleinsten
bekannten teilchen der materie insgesamt
kennen wir zwölf von ihnen
beziehungsweise sechs quarks und sechs
anti kriegs sie sind nie alleine
anzutreffen auch nicht in experimenten
und unterteilen sich in sechs arten die
sechs verschiedene fahrten nennt man
auch quax flavours sie sind wiederum in
drei familien unterteilt die sich nach
ihrer masse unterscheiden es gibt up und
down strange und charme und top und
bottom quarks die erste generation der
quasi up down familie ist die leichteste
und die dritte generation die top bottom
familie die mit der größten masse warum
sich die elementarteilchen ausgerechnet
in drei familien zusammen finden und
nicht in fünf oder noch mehr dass es
noch nicht klar und bleibt ein rätsel
für die heutige physik sowie ein elektro
negativ und ein proton positiv geladen
ist haben auch quarks eine elektrische
ladung allerdings ist diese nicht ganz
zahl ich das ab klagt beispielsweise die
ladung plus zwei drittel das down krank
- ein drittel wenn man also 2 down platz
und einen abgang zusammenbringt hat das
gebilde der drei quarks keine
elektrische ladung nach außen weil sich
die werte aufheben und so setzt sich
auch das neutronen zusammen dass mit
diesen drei quarks als bausteine keine
elektrische ladung trägt neben der
elektrischen haben fans auch noch eine
weitere ladung die farb ladung damit
lassen sich sehr gut die möglichen
zusammenschlüsse aus quarz
veranschaulichen die ja nie
als einzelne teilchen vorkommen sondern
immer in hadronen gebunden sind sie
kommen also immer im zusammenschluss von
zwei drei oder mehr quarks vor wie beim
neutronen sie können drei werte der
fachplanung annehmen rot grün oder blau
die anti kriegs haben entsprechend die
farbwerte antidot anti grüne und anti
blau und es sind nur die qual
kombination stabil bei denen die farb
ladung zusammen weiß ergeben das kann
man sich abstrakt vorstellen wie wenn
man mit drei scheinwerfern diese farben
an eine wand werfen sie überlagern sich
und es entsteht weiß es nicht völlig neu
sind tetra und pentax übrigens nicht in
der physik wird schon länger über
potenzielle märkte zuständig spekuliert
also partikel die zum beispiel aus zwei
quarks und zwei anti kriegs
zusammengesetzt sind es war also schon
bekannt dass sich quarks zwar
typischerweise in zweier oder
dreiergruppen so hadronen verbinden aber
gleichzeitig wurde schon lange in
modellen errechnet dass es auch teilchen
mit vier oder fünf geben muss im jahr
2013 sind japanische und chinesische
forschende dann auf die ersten tetra
quarks gestoßen diese konnten dann schon
ein jahr später am cern gezeigt werden
die damals gefundenen tetra quarks
bestanden aber aus anderen quarks als
das jetzt gefundene teilchen teilchen
mit vier quarks sind schon etwas
besonderes der satz spricht man in der
physik sogar von exotischen teilchen das
neue teilchen ist aber das exotischste
dass man bisher finden konnte denn es
ist das erste das aus vier schweren
quarks derselben art besteht aus vier
jumps genauer gesagt aus zwei charme und
zwei anti charme quarks davor wurden im
lhc b und den anderen experimenten nur
tetra quarz mit höchstens zwei schweren
quarks nachgewiesen und noch nie eins
mit mehr als 2 quarks desselben typs
übrigens konnten die vorständen auch
schon ein pentax finden 2017 wurde ein
solches zeichen aus vier quarks und
einem anti quark entdeckt das neue
teilchen entdeckte die forschungsgruppe
indem sie daten der ersten beiden
laufzeiten des lhc des weltweit
leistungsstärksten
teilchenbeschleunigers durchforsteten
die daten sind auf solchen ländern
gespeichert das hier habe ich vom cern
und die daten stammt in diesem
von experimenten aus den jahren 2009 bis
2013 und 2015 bis 2018 und wurden nach
ereignissen durchsucht bei denen
auffallend viele kollisionen im
beschleuniger dokumentiert wurden in den
daten zeigten sich dann erhebung
sogenannte bams die den standard wert
von 50 überschritten denn ab diesem wert
gelten die ergebnisse als signifikant
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es sich dann
noch um einen zufallsfund handelt
beträgt bei diesem wert nur noch eins zu
35 millionen
das war bei der entdeckung des neuen
teilchens namen sixx 6900 der fall doch
was bringen uns überhaupt diese
entdeckung neues wissen über die
kleinsten bekannten elementarteilchen
und darüber wie sich quax miteinander
verbinden für ein stück für stück zur
lösung der großen rätsel der physik dazu
gehört beispielsweise auch die frage was
dunkle materie ist forschende vermuten
dass sie aus hexa quarks bestehen könnte
die als kondensate durchaus stabil genug
werden um die dunkle materie zu bilden
außerdem können solche entdeckungen zur
erklärung vom physikalischen beobachtung
beitragen die einfach nicht in das
standardmodell der physik passen wollen
penta quads und trucks können vor allem
dabei helfen einen der vier grundkräfte
der physik besser zu verstehen
die starke wechselwirkung die die atome
in sich zusammen hält diese kraft bindet
protonen neutronen und atomkerne aus
denen die uns bekannte materie besteht
genauere kenntnisse zur starken
wechselwirkung sind auch wichtig um neue
unerwartete prozesse dahingehend
einordnen zu können ob sie ein zeichen
für neue physik eben oder nur für die
standard physik sind diese entdeckung
gibt uns also weitere aufschlüsse über
die grundkräfte der physik wie bedeuten
diese forschung ist und wie viel man
dafür investieren will wird übrigens
gerade heiß diskutiert denn europäische
forschende des cern wollen einen
gigantischen teilchenbeschleuniger über
100 kilometer lang bauen der 20
milliarden euro kosten soll
denn je mehr man über die kleinsten
bausteine der welt wissen möchte desto
größer müssen die geräte seien mit denen
man sie erforschen kann und das lhc
kommt mit seinen 27 kilometern
allmählich an seine grenzen auch wenn es
vor kurzem gerade aufgerüstet wurde wir
hatten ja hier darüber berichtet der
large cap
collider am cern wird zum super
beschleuniger anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar diesen kanal hier
klick zum science and future bis dann
bleibt dran